hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
central concepts or notions in gabrielle
Marcel's concrete approaches to
investigating the ontological mystery is
of course that last term mystery what
what does he mean by mystery why is he
bringing that up in here it doesn't that
have too much of a religious connotation
and towards the end of his essay he
actually considers that that that
particular objection that might be made
if you're not talking about mysteries of
say the Christian faith then why are you
using this term which could be easily
confused with that on the other hand why
are you using this word mystery when it
might be something like a mystery that
Sherlock Holmes solves or that
scooby-doo solves Marcel doesn't
actually consider that because those
sorts of things would be what he calls
problems and we'll look at that in just
a moment but it's worth actually looking
at what he says in the end about this
possible confusion with a Christian
sense of mystery as well he says we'll
some say the use of the word mystery
Rick risks
excreting an equivocation and fostering
a confusion I refuse and he says I
answer there is no question of confusing
those mysteries enveloped in human
experience as such so this here's where
he's going to tell us what some of these
mysteries actually are knowledge love
for example and revealed mysteries so
there won't be any confusion between the
things that are part of our existential
condition you might say and then
revealed mysteries such as the
Incarnation and the redemption he says
no effort of reason alone reflecting on
experience can enable us to attain to
these latter mysteries but reason alone
or there really is no such thing as
reason alone but the reason of the
concrete existing human being within the
situation's that they inhabit can
reflect upon mysteries such as that of
loving another person falling in love
falling out of love the mystery of evil
which he says is not actually the
problem of evil but rather a mystery the
mystery of the connection between the
body and the soul or the mind or
whatever it is the spirit whatever is
non-reducible simply to the body the
mystery of presence of participation
even a mystery of what constitutes
knowledge for Marcelle so all of these
are things that we can reflect upon and
they have their proper province within
philosophy particularly existential
philosophy that's not to say that they
can't be dealt with in many other ways
Marcel himself was a playwright and
approached things that he considers to
be mysteries through his dramatic
situations as we'll talk about now a
mystery is something for Marcel that is
distinct from but could fade into and to
generate back into what he calls a
problem and he thinks that much of our
current culture and the world that we
live in and the people that we are
is concerned primarily with problems
things that can be solved things that
are matters of desire and fear things
that we can formulate for ourselves
separate out and treat one by one or if
we like we're being ambitious treat in
multiple ways through what he calls
techniques things that could be the same
for you as they could be for me again
you know I've used the example
previously of YouTube tutorials those
are things that solve problems they
don't really raise mysteries unless we
start thinking about what is the nature
of my learning from another human being
whose image I'm seeing and yet maybe
dead or is located halfway around the
world or to take another example my
YouTube avatar if you look at the total
number of minutes viewed has at this
point lived more than twice as long as I
have out there in the ether what what is
that that's not a problem
that's more like what Marcel is calling
a mystery so let's let's see what he
actually has to say what he has to tell
us about these very important moral and
metaphysical enquiries situations ways
in which were rooted in being he tells
us that problems only go so far and we
can get past them
through an inquiry that is situated
beyond the problematical that goes
beyond it it doesn't mean that it's
there's somehow two realms that are
entirely separate from each other like
some sort of you know material realm
that we live in and then some ideal
realm or anything like that no they they
inter penetrate each other but it is
possible to go beyond the problematical
so he tells us that it is meta
problematical that is the the word that
he uses and we should talk about what
this meta actually means
here's an example of this he says I'm
inclined towards the affirmation of the
recognition of a participation that has
the reality of a subject this
participation cannot by definition be
the object of thought it could not
function as a solution but is rather
situated beyond the world of problems it
is meta problematical it goes beyond the
meta is much like the meta of
metaphysics this comes originally from
Aristotle and the books that we call the
metaphysics are meta tahu Sica they are
beyond the realm of the nature or things
that grow or the physical and they have
to do with being as such something that
undergirds underlies and yet penetrates
up into the merely physical right that's
the way a meta problematical thing
becomes a mystery it's not meta in the
way that other people might talk about
it for example when we think about meta
language right when we say we're doing a
metalinguistic thing we're using
language about language and generally
when we're doing philosophy of language
or linguistics the meta linguistic is
understood is sort of you know
referential above the other language it
governs it it tells it what to do we can
understand this sort of algorithmically
that's understanding it in a
problematical way still so meta
problematical he tells us a couple
different formulations of mystery all of
which are a little bit metaphorical but
can give us a good sense of it a mystery
he says is a problem that encroaches on
its own data what does that mean that
means that there's a certain self
referentiality and you might even say a
certain subjectivity there how does that
happen well problems exist for us
but they can be separated out from us
mysteries include us
they involve us they entangle us and
sooner or later were the one sort of
providing the driving engine the problem
can actually be applied to itself
you see Plato dealing with things like
this and asking questions rather
innocuously like well is justice itself
just that's not a problem that's more of
a what Marcel is calling a mystery a
problem that encroaches on its own data
he also tells us that there's a little
bit later a mystery involves reflection
reflecting on reflection or what Marcel
likes to call second reflection when
we're engaged in the world of problems
we are doing reflection we are thinking
about things say that last year and in
French means to think about to ponder to
consider right and so I might consider a
technical problem like how do I make
this book look as if I haven't been
setting it down in the way that it is or
where should I put the bookmarks in this
book right or how do I tie this tie I
can think about those things I can also
think about is this a proper time for me
to be wearing a tie what do I want to
convey to you the viewer that might be
something that's a problem as well but
it might start to extend into the realm
of mystery why should I be wearing a
time what is it connote ik is it because
I'm wearing as some people have called
it the part of the uniform of the
bourgeoisie no is it just because I love
wearing ties no it's because I want to
convey a certain sort of seriousness or
taking something as being important I've
done this with my students since I began
teaching and I was not a person who wore
tights much before that
nor am i a person who wears ties much
outside of this context or in business
and now notice I'm involved in this
question it's not purely subjective
though your understanding it you're
hearing it there's a connection possible
for you it can turn just into a problem
for you how do I understand dr. Sadler
or let me get him past his tie
predicament or something like that but
it also offers the possibility for some
sort of dialogue some sort of genuine
communication some sort of sharing some
sort of participation over you know
rather trivial example that can mean
much much more we're involved whether we
realize it or not in opportunities to
explore mysteries all of the time that
sometimes more than others and weddings
at funerals at births at you know
getting an award losing an award
consoling a friend who has had a
terrible breakup applying for a job all
of these things are within the realm of
the problematical at first but then can
be part of the mystery right and that
involves reflection on reflection
thinking about what you what you're
thinking and how other people think
about it and then thinking about that
some more it doesn't mean to lose
yourself entirely in abstraction in a
way this provides a possibility for
things to be even more concrete he also
tells us another formulation that a
problem or a mystery is a problem is a
wonderful phrase that trespasses on its
own givenness or data and I like that
that term trespasses because it implies
a certain sense of you know going beyond
what the rules are allowing but the
rules don't don't matter so much here so
what then is this beyond what is the
mysterious Marcel thinks that it's
inevitably going to be
it involves us within the problem as
those for whom the problem exists we
become conscious of ourselves not just
as problem solvers but as those who in
some way contribute to how the problem
is formulated or how the problem is
being looked at or whether we even need
to go beyond it and view it no longer
just as a problem but perhaps as an
opportunity as a dialogue as an exchange
as a mystery he also thinks that
mysteries are dramatic they're not
purely personal in the sense of being
intensely you know involving one subject
for whom you know they carry this
terrible burden by themselves know most
of these arise within a life that we
share together not necessarily a life
that we understand entirely either on
our own or with each other we don't
always have the same viewpoints on it
the same perspectives but we are within
dramatic situations as you might say
characters are in a play Marcel was a
great playwright so you understood that
it also involves us with something
beyond ourselves and it may be something
greater than ourselves
quite often the key to understanding
something fully is a mystery is a sense
of humility about our own part and how
much we matter in relation to something
greater he tells us that that we are
involved in how we grasp this and
there's a lot of scope for how personal
development or choices or the habits
that we develop would play a role in
this and he discusses that at different
points in this for example do we feel
hope or despair that's not a simple
choice that we turn on or off but it
does involve our being and our choices
and our relations to
other things out there and despairing
may make it impossible for us to grasp
certain mysteries that hope could open
up to us he goes on and he tells us that
mysteries are as he says real there's a
really great discussion here
he says the meta problematical some
people might say is just a content of
thought why not inquire about its mode
of existence as such what assures us of
his existence how do we know that any of
this stuff really exists is this not
itself problematical to the highest
degree he says my response to this is as
categorical as can be to think the meta
problematic is to affirm it as
indubitably real to think it is to
affirm it there is no thinking it and
denying it at the same time and to
affirm it as being indubitably real that
is it cannot be doubted this is sort of
like the Cartesian coach ito he tells us
something I cannot doubt without
contradiction something that doubt
doesn't really make sense and he says we
are in a zone where it's impossible to
dissociate the idea itself from the
degree of certitude that it carries this
idea is certitude it is its own
assurance and to that extent is
something other and more than an idea
now this is not to say that mystery has
suddenly become you know transparent and
and you know they they present
themselves with perfect certainty to us
like for example the mystery of evil but
we know that the mystery exists we know
that we're dealing with something that
matters that is real that isn't just in
our heads or in social discourse or a
figment of you know some persons
imagination that's been transferred to
us in some way we're dealing with
something that has reality you could say
in itself if that wasn't a little bit
misleading
in itself in such a way as it can reach
to us and we can proceed into it might
be another way of saying it now there is
a one more thing to discuss in
clarifying this notion of mystery and
that is a temptation Marcelle says that
there is not a clear dividing line with
mystery on one side and problem on the
other and we can just say Oh leave those
problems behind go them over here to the
mysteries this is where the real action
is or anything like that that would be
nonsense in part because we do in fact
have a world of legitimate problems that
we do have to address not everything has
to be a mystery but if there are
mysteries then we want to be able to
acknowledge them as such and it's a
struggle sometimes to be able to do so
especially for people who are used to
thinking everything of everything in
terms of problems to be solved for
whatever reason however they managed to
get into that situation even for those
of us who are willing to say yes there
there are mysteries there's still a
temptation to reduce mysteries to
problems why because problems are more
tractable they're more manageable
they are solvable we might be able to
come up with some sort of technique for
addressing them and so there's a
constant temptation that we have to
struggle against to reduce mysteries or
degenerate mysteries to problems he
tells us that one thing that we can see
is that a mystery placed before
reflection he says tends inevitably to
degrade itself into a problem and he
gives us an example of that the mystery
which we easily see did you to generate
itself into the problem of evil
something to be solved by philosophers
through arguments another thing that he
does tell us
well is that the mystery of being in
some respect lies beyond knowledge he
says that to admit the meta
problematical is to acknowledge the
premise II of being over knowledge now
to being as affirmed but rather of being
affirming itself it is to recognize that
knowledge is enveloped by being that it
is in some manner interior to being he
says from this point of view as opposed
to what epistemology the study of
knowledge strives vainly to establish
there really is a mystery of knowledge
knowledge derives from a mode of
participation no theory of knowledge can
account for because the theory itself
presupposes this participation it's a
very common mistake in not only modern
philosophy but in many other fields to
begin from a demand that epistemology be
addressed before everything else and
that's a demand that everything be
treatable in terms of some sort of neat
tidy theoretical presentation or some
sort of technique and what that ignores
is the fact that even bringing up
knowledge itself is already a mystery
it's a mystery within being not the
reverse where knowledge would reveal to
us all the conditions of being so
hopefully this gives you some sense of
what Marcel means in speaking about a
mystery and how it differs from a
problem
you